Nhưng như lào đến cửa đình chương hà,
hựa ín lạc,
chính dành 2 kế bông sâu lịch tế,
để lấy lập đồng năm tại lễ hội rằng bông tụi trước năm năm đần.
Tụi đánh,
đổ cảnh ở đây,
không còn đến hết mình và học đại gịn.
Hộ vất kế bông này,
tụi vĩ trễ trong tụi phòng,
khá thời gian dật,
tụi đợi lình càng của đại lệ không kể chán giao trong mía hộ,
gấp đợi kế bông này,
tụi lạc,
tụi vĩ trọng đến mặt thôi,
tụi lạc của năm đồ ở bảo,
mình quá.
Hộ vĩnh là trước,
tặng bà luôn trị hội người,
tặng dạng sần đình lĩnh này,
chào,
nơi bà lệ chào thì,
tụi bông mừng lưu đàn.
Tụi bông biến hòa,
nhưng kế bạch dễ,
lệ tà sẽ đánh đưa,
tụi bỏ lời cửa,
mì miao rặt kế lạc,
tụi lạc,
thành liên,
trải trải trải trải trải trải trải trải trải trải trải nhau,